lives depend on the new covid vaccine
but for it to work it needs to be kept
at minus
80. the moment it leaves the cryo
freezer
at pfizer's manufacturing plant in
belgium it's packed in dry
ice and sent to clinics in a super
insulated box
it's so cold that it's beyond the
existing frozen supply chain for other
medical products
the key thing in this approach is the
amount of product we're talking about
and the speed at which we would want to
move
it that is an unprecedented challenge
the difference between it being at
temperature and not being at temperature
is it the
medicine working or not working it's as
simple as that
dry ice is frozen carbon dioxide
its natural temperature is minus 80
degrees
is by chance that this is the low-tech
solution to moving around the world
such a high-tech vaccine traditionally
vaccines have contained either a killed
version of the virus or fragments of it
but they need to be made in
manufacturing facilities with tight
biosecurity
the pfizer vaccine contains short
segments of
rna the genetic instruction to make part
of the spike
protein which coats the outside of the
virus
once injected the rna turns muscle cells
into spike
protein factories triggering an immune
system memory
in case the real virus is encountered in
future
the challenge now is to distribute 40
million doses that the uk has bought
to those who need it the most i have
tasked the nhs
with being ready from any date from the
1st
of december the logistics are complex
the uncertainties are real and the scale
of the job is vast gps could staff
large vaccination centers seven days a
week to protect
people as fast as possible but the
vaccine is
unlike anything they're used to it'll
need to be unfrozen
it'll need to be diluted and you need to
be drawn up into separate syringes and
then administered
so there are a number of steps which
general practice isn't doesn't
traditionally have to
carry out when it gives a large-scale
vaccination program
but they're not insurmountable
the uk has enough of the vaccine for 20
million people
short of the 30 million that the
government immunization experts consider
to be at risk of serious disease
[Applause]
but it is a start and if it's approved
by safety regulators
roll out will begin immediately in the
most extraordinary
logistical challenge thomas more sky
news